بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول
الله واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان
محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول الله
تعالى ولله يسجد من في السماوات والارض
طوعا وكرها وظلالهم بالغدو
والاصال هذه
الايه من ايات
السجده الاربعه
في كتاب
الله والعلماء
اختلفوا في عدد السجدات في
القران والذي عليه اكثر طبعات المصحف تجد
الخط فوق ايه
السجده
مع تصوير لمحراب
مسجد فهذا
هو المتعارف
عليه في هذه
الطبعه
وكذلك في
مصحف المصحف
المصري والمصحف المكي والمصحف
المدني وغالب
مصاحف
المشارقه الذين يعتمدون العد الكوفي
والسجدات
على المذهب الحنبلي
والشافعي
والسجود عند قراءه هذه
الايات قيل انه
واجب وقيل انه مستحب
والراجح انه
مستحب لفعل النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بما
يدل على
استحبابه وكذلك لفعل
الصحابه رضي الله
عنه روى الامام مالك ابن
انس رحمه الله تعالى امام دار الهجره في
وطائه ان عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه قام
خطيبا على المنبر
يوما فقرا ايه فيها
سجده فنزل عن المنبر
وتهيا الحضور
للسجود فسجد وسجدوا
معه
ثم عاد الى مقامه على المنبر واخذ في تالي
خطبته
ثم جاء الاسبوع القادم وهذا في خطبه
الجمعه فقام خطيبا على المنبر مره اخرى
فقرا الايه
نفسها وفي بعض الروايات انها ايه من سوره
النحل
فته الناس للسجود فقال على
رسلكم فانما هي اذا
شئنا على رسلكم يعني
استنوا السجود انما هو اذا شئنا ايش يعني
اذا شئنا يعني على الاستحباب واراد رضي
الله عنه ان يعلم
ذلك و على ذلك وهذه من اقوى الادله لذلك
اكتفى بهذا دليلا الامام مالك رحمه
الله
لماذا لان عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله
عنه له
خاصيه من بين الصحابه هو وابو بكر في جامع
الترمذي النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
اتبعوا الذي من بعد ابا بكر
وعمر
وكذلك جعل لابي بكر وعمر رضي الله عنهما
سنه
متبعه هي تعتبر من بقايا سنه النبي صلى
الله عليه
وسلم فيقول فعليكم بسنتي وسنه الخلفاء
الراشدين المهديين من بعدي عضوا عل
بالنواجد واياكم ومحدثات
الامور وكذلك عمر رضي الله
عنه في
عصره في زم
خلاه كان صمه الدوله الاسلاميه
فيدين وكان هو خطيب
المدينه
واكثر اصحابه صحابه
فاكثر الحاضرين هم
صحابه فما يفعله او يقوله عمر رضي الله
عنه على المنبر اكثر من استدلال به الامام
مالك رحمه الله في الموطا
لماذا لانه اذا ما في حدا انكر عليه او رد
عليه او قال بخلافه واكثرهم صحابه هذا يدل
على ماذا ن من الاجماع وهذا هو عمل اهل
المدينه عند الامام مالك رحمه
الله جاء في صحيح الامام مسلم من حديث ابي
هريره ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال اذا
قرا
احدكم ايه السجده فسجد
اعتزل الشيطان
يبكي
يقول امر ابن ادم بالسجود فسجد فله الجنه
وامرت بالسجود فابيت فلي النار هذه روايه
صحيحه وهذا حث من النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم على
السجود
كذلك جاء في صحيح الامام الب
بخاري ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
قرا قرا ايه سوره الانشقاق اذا السماء
انشقت فسجد وسجد الصحابه الحضور
معه وجاء في بعض الروايات ان ذلك كان في
صلاه
العشاء
كذلك
جاء ادله كثيره جاءت تدل على
استحباب سجود
التلاوه وان اكثر عمل الصحابه واكثر عمل
النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم على السجود الا
انه ليس عزيمه يعني ليس
فرضا لماذا اكثرنا في هذا العلماء الفقهاء
رحمهم
الله قد استفاض خلافهم في هذه المساله
فبعضهم اغرب جاء
بمسائل جاء بمسائل غريبه شويه
لماذا لانك اذا اعتقدت
وجوب سجود
التلاوه فانه ينبني على هذا
الاعتقاد واجبات اخرى
يعني تقرا مثلا لابن حزم في
المحلى رحمه الله
يحرم سامعين يعني
يحرم القراءه بايه
للامام فيها
سجده في الصلاه السريه يعني الظهر والعصر
ققول لك
ممنوع هذا الان تحريم من يحرم قراءه شيء
من القران في الصلاه شيء
عجيب وعلى كل
حال ف السجده مستحبه والسجده ليست
صلاه
لذلك جازت
السجده الى اي جهه لا يشترط في هذه السجده
سجده التلاوه كذلك سجود
الشكر لا اي
يجب استقبال القبله ولا
الوضوء غير ذلك ميجب على الساجد في صلاته
الوضوء واقبال القبله
للاه واما
السجده ف عندنا
ادله من الصحبه رضي الله عنهم
وغيرهم تدل على انها لا تلحق بالصلاه حكما
لكن
الاكمل الاكمل لسجود التلاوه كيف الانسان
يستقبل القبله ويسجد متوضئا متطهرا ساترا
لعورته هذا هو الاكمل لماذا اكمل لانه
اجمع على هذه الهيئه العلماء رحمهم الله
واما التكبير والتسليم فلا يثبت
بحال يقول تعالى ولله يسجد من في السماوات
والارض طوعا وكرها وظلالهم بالغدو
والاصال ولله يسجد هنا
جاء جاء شبه الجمله جاءت التي تسد مسد
الخبر جاءت متقدمه على
المبتدا ايش يعني هذا الكلام يعني اصل
الجمله ويسجد
لله
لكن جاءت الايه ولله يسجد هذا يدل على
حصر يعني لله يسجد من في السماوات والارض
لا
لغيره وانما لغير الله يسجد شيء يسير من
خلق الله
الضالين في في بقاع من الارض واما
لله
فسبحانه يسجد له من في السماوات
والارض وايضا قال
من وهذا اسم
موصول لما يعقل يعني العقلاء اشرف خلقه
سبحانه وتعالى يسجدون
له يقول ولله يسجد اي لا
لغيره من في السماوات
والارض
طوعا وهم المؤمنون وهو على مراتب العبوديه
ان
الانسان يعلم عن الله ويتغلب على شهوته
فيسجد
لله يعني
الان جاء الخلاف
بين بعض الفرق
المنحرفه في تاريخ الاسلام وبين اهل السنه
في مساله تفضيل الملائكه على الانس هل
الملائكه افضل من الانبياء
مثلا الجواب
لا علماء اهل السنه اجمع على ان الانبياء
خير خلق الله وان افضل خلق الله على
الاطلاق وقيل
من المخلوقات من الملائكه والجن والانس هو
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم عليه افضل الصلاه
والسلام
الملائكه صحيح هي اكمل عباده من الانسان
صح وهي اكثر عباده من
الانسان
صحيح لكن
الملائكه صحيح لهم الاختيار يختارون ان
يعبدوا الله ولذلك امتدح الله
طاعتهم فقال لا يعصون الله ما امرهم
فليسوا مجبورين بل
هم
يختارون عباده الله ولا يفترون عن عباده
الله
لكن الملائكه ليست لهم
شهوه تفتنهم عما يعلمون من حق
الله الانسان له
شهوه الانسان له دافع
طبعي وشهوه
وميول واما الملا
فه مخلوقه من
نور وهي لا تستشعر ما يستشعر به
الانسان الانسان لما يقوم يعبد
الله فانه
ياتيه
وساوس النفس الاماره وتات الدنيا تشغله
وياتيه الشيطان
يوسوس وياتيه
شياطين الانس وياتيه الكسل وياتيه
وياتيه
ف يقوم بعباده الله رغم كل
هذه الامور فهذه عباده عظيمه
جدا
فبذلك في تلك اللحظه فهو اعظم من الملائكه
الملائكه لا تستطيع التوصل الى هذه الدرجه
لماذا
لان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول ان عظم
الجزاء مع عظم
البلاء
لكن
الانسان اذا تغلبت عليه هذه
الوساوس وعصى
الله
و عاص الله سبحانه وتعالى مع ان الملائكه
تامره
بالمعروف والملائكه لها لمه بابن
ادم
وكذلك عصى الله سبحانه وتعالى مع انه يعقل
عن الله ويحفظ كلام الله والى غير
ذلك
فحينئذ في
هذه فانه يكون كون دون
الدواب
لماذا لان الوحوش والهوام
والدواب فهي في
الحقيقه لا عقل لها لا اختيار لها ما
عندها
اختيار هي مجرد عباره عن دوافع طبيعيه
تدفعها فهي
تستجيب
لذلك فيقول
الحكماء رحمهم الله
تعالى
يقولون من اطاع الله كان خيرا من
الملائكه ومن عصى الله كان دون
الدواب فقوله تعالى لله يسجد من في
السماوات والارض يعني لله
يسجد من خلقه
العقلاء ومن لهم
اختيار وبالرغم من
الدوافع والوساوس
والهواجس فيجدون لله بالرغم من ذلك
كله من في السماوات وهم
الملائكه والارض وهم الانس
والجن وجميع الخلق
طوعا
يعني يطيعون بذلك الله يعني رضاء من
انفسهم
اختيارا وكرها وهم
الكفار فقد لا يسجدون
لله في حين تكبرهم
ولكن اذا ضاقت بهم السبل وضاقت عليهم
الارض بما رحبت فانهم يسجدون
لله وكذلك اذا ماتوا
وحشروا الى القهار فانهم يسجدون لله فلله
يسجد من في السماوات والارض
طوعا اختيارا
وكرها يعني غصب عنهم
وظلالهم يعني ليس فقط هم بل
ظلالهم يقول تعالى يتفيا ظلاله عن اليمين
والشمال والله سبحانه وتعالى يسجد الظل
له وفي هذا سر لان
الظل من اثار وجود
الخلق يقول بالغدو وهي
البكر
يقول
تعالى
بالغدو
البكر يعني اول
النهار
والاصال
والاصال يعني العشاي اخر
النهار لله
يسجد
في جميع الوقت وظلالهم
خاصه بالغدو والاصال لان الظل يمتد في هذا
الوقت نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم صلى
الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد
يست ان سوره
الرعد الله سه
وتعالى
15 سه
الر سه الر 13
قران
0 صل الله عليه
وسلم
‏ex
was
mid س
الر we know that was red in me because
are me in nature we also have
the
ق مجاهد ابن
عسه but also we know specifically that
was in that mid
time that midle
time
mean after inv isam
before
the
‏physically beaten and persecuted and
so forth how do we know this so be
roughly
about the third year after he was
appointed as a prophet to about the
sixth year or sth year right just before
they went into the
the شعب of اب طالب ‏when the now how
do we know this we know this from
the the tone of the
chapter we know this from the tone of
the
chapter the tone of the chapter is
ramping
up
agression and it's obviously responding
to ridicule
صل الله عليه
وسلم
عليه الصه
والسلام الله سبحانه
وتالى you say that there is a day of jud
what about this what that resp
to
‏even
though that those asking the and making
these
arguments they a little they pretty
disingenuous with their question and
arguments for instance if you ask a
question in three tyes of people ask the
day of
jud is day of jud there tyes ‏people
that ask that
question the the believers who genuinely
want to know when is it so that they can
prepare for it or they asking because
they want that knowledge if it's
available the second
type are those are
testing the propet صل الله عليه
وسلم
the jews of medina for instance the
rab there
‏testing him they trying to see if he
knows and usually the response to
that will be with some of the signs of
the day of judgment as per mention in
the previous
books and then there's those who
ask
rhetorically out
mockery when is this day of
juds and we know the type of question by
the answer
‏weever who
making making
fun so we know that was in this era the
first years
before the first years the propet الله
عليه وسلم
was
those ‏some of them were secret some of
them you know he did not announce his
prophethood to everyone at once it was
just it was in phases first it was to
him then it was to his close family and
relatives then it was to his tribes then
it was to generally the people of meca
and after that it was to everyone so
there was a time when it was
kind but
also
‏was the first
years that third
year on
into
ران
disbeliever and responding to questions
that they're asking and we see the type
of questions that they're
asking based on that we
can
roughly when ‏was this chapter raled
when were these verses
revealed and
so this chapter was
revealed not in the first
years
apparently but before the sth
year
apparently but it's number 13 in the
order of chapters from the beginning to
the end
مصح عثم رضي الله
عنه
قران order that ration was صل الله عليه
وسلم
dict الله سبحانه
وتالى ‏says that translates to and to
allah and he
alone
prostates
those whom are in the heavens and the
earth willingly and
unwillingly as well as their as their
shade in the mornings and in the
evenings this is another distinction
الله سبحانه
وتعالى all false deities worship aside
from
he and that is that these false deities
these false
idols
even those who worship angels or
prophets or
saints these saints and angels and
prophets if they really are angels or
prophets they do not san
‏even
these individuals
these entities worship
from they only have some pockets of some
misguided people praying for
them الله سبحانه وتالى
‏every prostrating to
him all of the time or the maor of the
time سبحانه وتالى
اللهون
pr those are in the
heavens those who are in the heavens and
the
earth
‏ang
and
hum those
disb pr سبحانه
وتعالى ‏prost him when they need beed
when in
trou when things are very bad when they
really need allah to fix their problem
for
them such as allah tells us when they
are in a state of fam or in in a state
of
of you
know dr or when they are in a ship
‏waves
to around with the ship and kn it around
and they feel they're going to
be
dr prr
to don't pray to anys any el
point الله سبحانه
وتالى مشركين
قريش believer other types
of other places they
‏area
ofic as well as their shade in the
mornings and in even
all اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه
[Silence]
اجمعين